quand dans les manifs c'est les Black
Blocs dans ce genre de manifestations
publiques et qui comme elle est les
infractions
qui viennent des banlieues qui viennent
des quartiers qui viennent c'est qui
viennent des quartiers c'est pas la
vérité il y a eu quand même un mort
excuse malgré un drame je viens de le
dire maintenant il y a eu 10 millions
et bien sûr il y a eu 10000 policiers
qui ont été mobilisés sont précédents ça
veut dire que aujourd'hui pour la
sécurité on est obligé d'avoir 10000
policiers sur le territoire j'ai jamais
vu moi des gens en Porsche avec des
blousons Chanel en train de [ __ ] le
bordel sur les Champs-Élysées c'est pas
les bons c'est pas les bourgeois du 8e
qui foutent le bordel c'est bien des
gens qui viennent de banlieue il se
passe des choses incroyable en banlieue
génial mais c'est quand même les gens
des quartiers populaires qui viennent
sur les champs il y a pas un type de
jeunes de pain il y a des gens d'où
viennent les gens